[Music]
hollywood sensation chris pratt is known
for numerous movies most notably the
relatively recent that tomorrow war and
of course his iconic role is star lord
and guardians of the galaxy the 42 year
old has already proven on several
locations that he can also be convincing
behind the camera namely in a recording
studio for instance pratt dubbed various
characters in both of the lego movie
films or in onward then a few weeks ago
there was this surprising announcement
that he would be voicing super mario in
an animated film and now the next report
is already hitting the news brad is to
dub garfield the cat in an upcoming
feature film the last movies from the
garfield universe were made in 2004 and
2006 where the cat was voiced by bill
murray though not fully animated at the
time this is now set to change as the
aim is to create an appealing feature
from using the latest technology we
don't know much more about the project
yet which also means we will have to
wait a little longer for a release date
production of the john wick spin-off
ballerina is already in full swing
according to deadline there is now a
contender for the lead role in the
spin-off namely knife's out actress anna
diamas the 33 year old cuban has been an
essential part of the film business for
several years so it comes as no surprise
that those in charge would like to have
her john the cast previously there was
speculation that chloe grace moretz
could play the lead role we already know
this spin-off's name given main
character from john week 3 where she can
be seen briefly she originates from the
same russian assassin school as john
wick whose real name is giordani
giovanovic and who became a professional
killer under the guidance of director of
rosco roma the young contract killer
named rooney brown went through the same
program as the star of the action
franchise she also shares an imprint in
motive with jovik namely revenge her
entire family was killed and thus she
sets out to find those responsible a
hint finally leads her to the tranquil
town of sunnyvale which is nothing more
than a safe haven for various
professional killers plus there's a
special trait awaiting fans of keanu
reeves asked the 57 year old is rumored
to be making a cameo appearance in the
spin-off a mini-series about the titular
continental hotel is also currently in
the works it'll be released in three
parts and will focus on its history
unfortunately there is no release date
for either project yet but as always we
will keep you up to date
in the past few weeks there has been
some news about christopher nolan's
latest project oppenheimer we recently
reported that emily blunt is in talks
for the role of robert oppenheimer's
wife and now there is already more to
report with matt damon and robert downey
jr two absolute top stars are joining
oppenheimer for robert downey jr in
particular it'll be a unique experience
because the 56 year old has never
starred in a nolan film before for nolan
in turn the new movie will also be very
exciting because after the publicity
racing split between the director and
warner brothers due to the various
disagreements over the release of his
films he is now producing for rival
universal pictures in terms of content
the blockbuster is about u.s scientist
robert oppenheimer who's generally
regarded as the father of the atomic
bomb as a result of his involvement in
the manhattan project the release date
for oppenheimer is set for july 21 2023
it is not yet known which exact roles
matt damon and robert downey jr are
going to play in the film
not all fans are thrilled that netflix
is planning a live action series for
avatar the last airbender comparable
movie adaptions have been too
disappointing in the past now the
streaming giant announced that they have
found a cast for the character ozai the
role of the tyrannical ruler and
self-proclaimed most powerful fire
banner in the world of avatar will be
played by last actor daniel day kim he
though succeeds star wars veteran mark
hamill who was the dubbing voice of ozai
in the animated series for several years
other well-known cast members include
gordon kumir as ang kyo and theo tarbell
as katara dallas leo as zuko and ian
oozley as soka exactly when the new live
action series will then be released on
netflix is yet to be determined but it
obviously seems to be moving forward
disney's adventure film national
treasure was released in 2004 at the
time the film was particularly
impressive with its advanced technology
and entertaining action for some time
now it has been known that disney would
like to further focus on the franchise
by producing its own spin-off series not
a lot is already known yet but disney at
least announced the leading actress a
few days ago as well as a brief outline
of the story the main role is to be
played by new camera lizard alexis who
recently starred in the horror film we
need to do something according to those
responsible the plot will revolve around
a young hero named jess morales although
she was born in the u.s her parents are
illegal residents of the united states
she quickly learns that there are other
secrets surrounding her family that are
just waiting to be uncovered in terms of
content the screenwriting couple marion
and cormac whibley are the ones in
charge while the directing is handled by
myra near the director of the original
john turtletop is acting as a
behind-the-scenes producer by the way at
the moment it is unfortunately not yet
clear when the national treasure series
will be available on disney plus
gal gadot's role as the leading actress
and producer of wonder woman 1984 didn't
really generate much enthusiasm now she
could be heading into a completely
different direction the remake of a
disney classic we are talking about the
movie company's snow white live action
adaption which has been in the planning
stages for several years now but has not
really made any progress in it cannot
could play the role of the wicked witch
who poisoned snow white by giving her an
apple the brothers grim fairy tale was
first adapted by disney in 1937.
according to deadline gedot is in the
final stages of her contract negotiation
meaning she will most likely be seen
alongside rachel zegler who is expected
to play the lead role disney strategy is
clear as they obviously want to build on
the very profitable remakes of old
classics as seen not least in 2019's the
lion king
nevertheless there should be a special
emphasis on snow white after all the old
movie was the very first full-length
animated film from disney at the time we
are eager to see who else will join the
cast and look forward to more news about
snow white
last august the first paw patrol movie
was released in the meantime the film
from the popular series has grasped an
impressive
135 million us dollars which is nearly
six times the cost of production
following the hit the second part has
now been confirmed and announced this
time it will be about a mysterious
meteorite that hits adventure city
giving our favorite four-legged friends
some magical powers however this is no
cause for celebration because in the
meantime mayor humdinger manages to
escape from prison and together with an
evil scientist tries to acquire their
superpowers as well sky is to be the
center of attention specifically as she
quickly realized that she has to
accomplish great things paw patrol the
mighty movie is already scheduled for
release on october 13
2023 which is less than two years away
looking for more stuff related to the
film and series world lucky you because
the new trailer of the book of boba fett
was released on our channel on tuesday
particularly for the fans of the
mandalorian this is an absolute
highlight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]